qui vous nomme tous les deux à la tête
du service rugolo le riz est notre
avenir vous n'engagez plus de terreur à
violer terreur bonjour les blagueurs
affecté à la mif c'est quoi exactement
l'amista et c'est parti de là maintenant
un terme fort style même qui
qu'aucune machine a besoin d'être
entretenue pour entretien at war
personne n'y arrive pas personne n'est
rien
[Musique]
et vous nomme tous les deux à la tête dû
servir ou golub le riz est notre ami
vous n'engagez plus de terreur a lieu
les terreurs bonjour les blagueurs
affecté à la mif c'est quoi exactement
la mishna et c'est parti il a maintenant
un terme force qui lui même qui
quand une machine a besoin d'être
entretenue plus entretien à toi
personne n'ait rien
[Musique]